I'm having breakfast.
Never forgive you, Nintendo.
Why is it so early?
You know what's funny is?
It's not even like...
It's only like an hour earlier than what I usually wake up.
I'm being dramatic.
But okay, I was working.
until 3 a.m.
last night, so...
You have to forgive me.
Vicky!
Ochu, Uma!
I was gonna raid you!
Good morning, Minky.
Good morning, you think Mike Tyson's house!
Good morning, Minto and I was like you.
It was worth getting up at 6.30 a.m.
I don't think so.
Good morning, Vito.
Can you see it too that you're really gifted?
Morning!
If you need more sleep, you can use my lap.
Oh my gosh, lap pillow offer?
Let's go.
Guys, this is Tomodachi Live!
We willed this into existence, remember?
This is huge.
This.
Tomodachi Live, hi.
What was I gonna say?
I don't remember.
Oh, I remember what I was gonna say.
I was gonna say, oh my gosh, so many things have been, like,
happening with, like, my favorite series is, like, the Fatal
Frame and Silent Hill F Collab.
I'm like, whoa.
I called Silent Hill F.
Fatal Frame for so long, I willed that into existence too.
I willed Silent Hill F and Fatal Frame because I kept
calling it Silent.
I mean, I kept calling it Fatal Frame.
Silent Hill Frame, exactly.
My boss, we are very cold, can you let us in?
You're literally on my couch, what are you talking about?
We're like so far apart though.
Holy moly, I thank you guys for all the super chats.
Thank you.
Better use $10 of my train ticket.
Train was an hour late?
Holy cow.
I am seated.
Silent Hill F is closer to Siren than it is to Fatal Frame.
You have to understand, I called it fatal frame when it was
before anyone had played it because of the visuals alone
please understand it's not because of how the game is at all
it's just the visual next to big ibu plush yeah that's
you're sitting he's he's cheese to be sitting on sat on so
happy i'm also jinking i got uh recently i got this like
it's like a yuzu honey tea but it's like a it's like a jam
shouken desu nice megane thank you minto tomodachi life for
me i came here i came here
What is Tomodachi life in Japanese?
Is it still Tomodachi life?
Don't forget to two times a stream.
You're right, you're right.
Whoa, we have, we still have 10 minutes.
Playback.
Two times.
What?
There's a four times!
What does that even benefit?
I don't know, let me turn off the comments on.
There you go.
Only for premium.
Oops.
Thanks for the voice pack.
I nearly died of a heart attack.
It was great.
Couple.
I want to say about the voice packs though, I think like, I
mean, obviously in the future I'm going to have a section
that says like, what name would you like me to use?
in it.
It was an oversight on my part.
I apologize.
Some people wrote like in the the request area like please
refer to me as blah blah blah or this will be for blah blah
blah so please refer to the name there.
But like ultimately there was no way of me knowing.
There was like actually no way of me knowing unless somebody
wrote it because all that all that I was provided was like
the name of the name of the person that like the legal name
so i'm really sorry if that was like a jump scare i'm so
sorry i boo afterlife i boo dachi after life seems too
fitting picking up early on my birthday bane happy birthday
i'm gonna sleep after this too little nap
Minto knows people's legal names Yeah, but I do not see I've
literally have forgotten Everything I remember if I wrote If
I recorded for your name And what it was Like if you told me
your YouTube name Or your Twitter name But
But for if it's your legal name I completely forgot No No
She does not perceive...
Yeah, don't spend...
I'm literally...
What if YouTube is a legal name?
Your real name is Ducky.
Like, it's funny because I'll record something and I'll use
the person's legal name because, like, if I'm recording a
voiceback, I want to...
I want to, like, you know, personalize it so I try to
include a name at all.
But...
It's funny because I won't know it's somebody until I see
like their tweet later and they'll be like, oh my gosh I
asked Minto to say this and she did and I'll be like, oh
that was for you.
Why didn't you write your name?
Why didn't you tell me it was for you?
Please it's It's the big day.
I'm so happy for you.
Thank you clockwork Just got and listen to my voice back.
See you!
How am I supposed to know it's Yu-Gi-Oh!
How am I supposed to say?
Not that I'm not gonna like, you know, make it very
exciting.
Like, you know, I put my full everything into each one.
But I want to be like, oh my gosh, this is for show and so.
Makes me excited too.
Shin-Solar, thank you for the time, Gifton.
Thank you guys for all the super chat, Solar.
My brain is waking up.
I almost turned off my alarm.
Wondering taco.
Thank you so much for the fun.
Good thing.
Thank you.
I almost turned off my alarm and was like, mmm, sleep.
So that's why I have my glasses on.
Breakfast is a cheese and a roll.
so many gifted this morning I know I know what's the
occasion what's going on is that girl breakfast that's ghost
breakfast ghost breakfast
now I got my tea it's cold I want to go back to bed I'll
never forgive you nintendo why is it so early especially for
pst 6 a.m i guess that's a normal jst time right first
english face i used to wait for the five-year-old thank you
this is like prime jst isn't it thank you they give her like
the permission to add minke to my tomodachi life world first
i want to see what's going on in this game watch they're
gonna give us a release date It'll be like today.
3 in the afternoon in EO.
So nice.
It's really late in JP time too though.
It's 11.
Oh, you're right.
It's 11 p.m.
It's not prime time at all in JP.
Crazy.
Nintendo Direct Watch Along back in 2024 was my first V2 and
V2 over stream.
That would have been a member for a year.
Oh my gosh.
It got six Vs.
It's so funny doing these directs, right?
These direct watch-a-logs.
Cheek-up, thank you!
Thank you so much for the gift.
I guess they were trying to hit as many time zones as
possible then.
They're like, Come on, West Coasters.
You can wake up at 6 a.m.
You gotta get to work anyway!
Hmm.
Alright, Japan, stay up.
Look alive, look alive.
Minito's stream while working makes the morning better.
Good morning, Minito.
Bring back the concert minigame.
Am I laughing as you were?
Right!
Can't complain about waking up to Minito.
Would you call the concert a minigame, though?
I'm really curious what kind of features they'll add.
I love Tomodachi.
life i love tomodachi life i love tomodachi life hawaiians
out here not asleep and not awake oh my gosh there's
gameplay meytopia creator in this game oh yeah that's
another big thing
So...
Yeah.
If you love Tomodachi life so much, why don't you marry it?
I'll marry Snake in the game.
I don't know.
Your streams control my sleep schedule.
Maybe this will fix my sleep schedule, so I'm not asleep at
3 a.m.
But to be fair, I had a meeting last night and that finished
at...
1.30?
1.30 a.m.
my time?
so uh and then i had some work to do afterwards crayon made
thank you so much for the fire get it
technically jp so pacific time
japan is also pacific time right right because Japan is oh
hello to everyone watching the Tomodachi life living the
dream direct I'm Yoshiaki Koizumi this game has me
characters me customize and interact with oh what is a me
you ask oh no all the kitties are like I don't know what
this is what kind of dream life awaits you in this new
tomodachi life game oh my god it's the exact same voice as
original tomodachi of tomodachi live the residents on this
island are called me characters it looks so the same and
you'll be the one creating them with you me your family oh
no and your friends lived here how about someone you really
admire Ooh, oh my God, my crush.
In Tomodachi life, living your life.
Your experience can differ based on the means you created
residents.
Let's see how you could be living the dream.
Oh yeah, getting a whole bowl of ramen from the vending
machine.
We'll begin by creating the first resident.
Yippee!
There are two main ways to make residents.
Get help?
You could start by answering questions about their facial
features.
Oh.
by creating each part individually.
Getting help from the...
Wait, what?
From scratch.
Let's try creating a college student.
She'll appear as a character throughout the direct.
From face types.
This is all the same.
Oh, new hairstyles.
Well, some new hairstyles.
Okay.
Sub-color.
Oh, wait, I can make my own hair color.
There are so many parts.
including ones unique to this game get help you can even
choose the shape of ears oh my god that's me you can adjust
their height and body type you'll also choose their name and
gender I'm all ears and if you like you can pick their
dating preferences oh oh my god pick their voice my name is
Angie my name is My name is Angie.
My name is Angie.
It's nice to meet you.
Then answer some questions about their personality.
Oh, my gosh.
And...
Everyone, meet Angie.
Angie!
An outgoing, friendly college student.
Sociable.
Hey, there.
It's nice to meet you.
Leader.
Leader?
I'm Angie.
I can't wait to start living here.
Oh, the voice is the exact same.
It's so good.
Oh, it looks like something is clouding Angie's mind.
Uh-uh.
What's up?
We can make mean to you!
How about some flan?
Yum.
I'm gonna have every girl crush ever.
You'll need to take care of your me at the start.
It's so lonely.
on Yumean Island.
Kind of gives me the heebie-jeebies too.
I wish there were other people here with me.
Ah, yeah, about that.
The island is pretty barren at first.
Oh, wow.
Angie needs some company, so let's create some new island
residents.
It feels small, no?
Is that just me?
It feels small.
First up is her childhood pal, Jess.
Jess.
Also Patrick.
He's kind.
And kind of aloof.
Dr. Winters.
Did you like your mentor?
She did.
Imagine making your professor.
A barista at the local cafe.
Imagine making your professor at this game.
One of Angie's friends from work.
Oh my god, the hairstyle is so cute.
Hugh Morris.
A jester and jokester.
Nobody talks about Hugh Morris.
Oh my god.
Angie's childhood teddy bear.
Just a bear.
You can even make me characters by combining different
features or by using face paint.
Oh my god, yes!
Oh, the customization.
As more residents appear, the island will grow.
Oh, nice!
Even if the residents are friends in the real world, they
won't know each other here.
At least at first.
There needs to be an opportunity for them to get acquainted.
D.
Let's try bringing Crystal a little closer to Jess.
Oh wow, you can like actually control where they go and
stuff.
Oh my gosh.
I can force my OTP to happen.
You're Crystal.
I'm Jess.
And now they know each other.
Getting familiar.
Once this happens, the mees will start interacting on their
own.
And depending on where you drop a me, I could force my OTPs
this is amazing different things might play out what is
going on why are you doing that hmm Angie what happened big
pause Osla I think dr. Winters and humorous would be best
friends love that idea what should we talk about to help
them get along so this is similar you could type something
Monster Truck.
Monster Trucks.
You can type anything!
Oh no.
Hey Morris, say hello to Dr. Winters.
Dr. Winters, this is T.
Morris.
Oh no.
Do you feel like talking about?
Monster Trucks?
Monster Trucks.
Tell me, Dr. Winters, did you see that report on TV
yesterday?
The one about Monster Trucks?
I've been itching to talk to someone about it.
Oh, no.
Oh, I was going to say, it was so boring that I fell asleep.
I guess I'm just not that interested in monster trucks.
I like the way he says it.
Monster trucks.
Oh, that reminds me.
Apparently, Dr. Winters made a cameo in the report.
Is that right?
Whoa.
You know, maybe we do have a lot to talk about after all.
I bet we could be good friends.
They hit it off.
Just barely, though.
On this island, time passes in the same way as the real
world.
So, even when you're not playing, the Mies will live their
lives of their own accord.
Can it tell you what?
Sure, I can get them out of it.
What is it?
Oh my God, fateful encounter.
sorry my mind was somewhere else no it's my fault Patrick so
dreamy
yeah I'm fine oh my god wait please we're both fine good
stay safe out there oh dreamy
Angie falling in love.
Hum, how curious.
Hum.
Anyway.
Let's introduce some of the shops that bring the island to
life.
First up is the food mart.
Fresh kingdom.
Shipping, I know.
It's going to be awesome.
Oh, cute.
The standard menus.
Avocado.
Some days, though, you might get some rather unusual
options.
String cheese.
Oh my gosh, please don't spoil what happens when they have a
favorite.
I want to see it.
This is the clothing shop.
Clothing!
And where?
You'll find a dolly dress outfit?
A sunny side up outfit.
So cute.
Anything clothes like a hot dog costume.
HOT DOG!
If you want to change up your look, head to this shop.
Hiya!
Next, the news station.
I love the news station though.
The original.
We've got a surprising news story for you.
Creature.
Early this morning.
Oh my gosh.
Picky's friend.
Only to be later identified as local resident Angie.
You can also rewatch the news later.
Ghost real!
The news segments were always one of my favorites.
T&C Reno.
There are rooms for people who want to be library dwellers
or who dream of living in a supermarket.
It looks so good.
She's so cute.
Wow!
Here's the marketplace where the items sold will change
based on the current time.
Step right up and try your luck.
Oh, this place is back.
Okay, it's this one.
Probably the best place.
along the island from great finds to unique mystery bags
interesting you might be surprised at what you discovered
lion at photo tomo you can choose a me uh-huh background
uh-huh and placement then snap a picture so cute try making
memories with the residents via photos
It's so cute!
Uh-oh.
It's Dr. Winters.
What's on your mind?
Nayami.
Yumi and doesn't have enough greenery.
Greenery?
Can we get some more plants around here?
That's a great idea.
Anything specific?
Greenery?
Okay.
Let's spruce things up.
Well, look at that!
the town's landscape looks beautiful thanks to dr winter's
idea trees on the sidewalk you can place landscaping items
across the island oh there's like a like a designing kind of
aspect oh wow so you can customize your island you can
purchase a variety of decorative items like benches and
plants oh you could even make a space for residents to hang
out Like this.
You can also move houses and shops around.
You can like just fully customize it.
What?
So go ahead and change things up to your liking.
Holy cow!
Double touch crossing.
Creating islands like these are possible with just your
imagination.
Holy cow!
What?
Oh my god, it's so cursed.
Here is an alien who's recently been popping up in Angie's
dreams.
Mocha's friend Latte has also been showing up.
The island's becoming pretty lively.
Wait, please, concert hall.
I don't see it.
Sporting a smug stance.
If it isn't Patrick.
Here's Dr. Winters, waddling around town.
Just alien is so funny.
Socializing skills and crossed arms at the ready.
Hi, my name is alien.
These tiny habits are called little quirks.
Little.
Oh, you just just float to me characters.
Wait, that's so fun.
You can kind of like customize their personality, like more
specifically.
The little quirks can differ.
What?
He's so baby girl.
for example.
Getting quirky.
Not the cool, me and Jess are not getting along.
You can also gift them with phrases.
Yeah!
I usually end up crying when I go to the movie.
I don't know.
Some other little quirks include wiping away sweat or
tossing and turning while asleep.
Try finding the little quirks that match each me.
It's so, it's so the same game.
Why so glum?
But better!
Did he reject you?
No!
Give it up!
No way!
This is so sad.
Let's get Hugh in here.
Hugh?
What is he gonna do?
We're talking to Alien.
No!
The...
Why can I never keep my hoodie?
strings even why the awkward like there's a rumor going
around that mocha is worried about you oh thank you so much
there's a rumor going i feel a little better mocha's worried
about you why is it a rumor oh no not the rebound
kindness and now now my heart seems to be racing why is it
humorous is angie falling for humorous the full name is so
funny we'll see how this unfold what is this kid drama angie
please oh it's crystal what the hell is that dog by her side
what but this pup isn't an ordinary pet no we could tell can
create it all thanks to this This workshop, Palette House.
I can make an eyeball!
Wait.
Here's how Crystal's dog is made.
Oh my god!
That's not the only thing you can create.
The flat they are!
Shut off, that's so cute.
Jess's favorite TV show?
Patrick's sweater that lights up the night.
You can make items to your heart's content.
Oh Hey, you could also design the exterior of a house and
the ground Yep, you can create items and use them for your
islands.
Oh my god, go wild and make what you want at pallet house Oh
my god
Hello the amount of oh my god, you couldn't customize
anything in the first game your mind anything I can't hold
back my feelings for humorous.
Oh, it's like humorous.
I need to tell him how I feel.
I'm like, I get it now.
We've got to cheer her on.
Where should I confess my love?
I love to always make them confess.
How about on the Ferris wheel?
Because it's always drama.
How should I confess my feelings?
It's humorous.
You just noticed.
Why not the old fashioned way?
No, we should have done it cutely.
I want to see.
The perfect locale for a profession of love.
Hugh Morris.
You just noticed.
Yeah, because I thought his name was Hugh Morris.
I, um, I, uh, you see.
So, Hugh Morris, I'm in love.
The ride's gonna end!
I'm in.
I know exactly what you're trying to say.
I'm totally in love with the view from here too.
Oh, Angie.
That's not what I was going to say.
Oh, she's still going for it.
I'm in love with you.
Can we go on a date?
The drama.
Oh my god, the suspense.
Hold it right there.
No.
From where?
The one who truly loves you, Morris, is me.
Oh my god, Jess!
Hold it right there.
What?
and dr winters too well the one who truly deeply loves
humorous is me i confess my feelings first that means i love
humorous the most humorous which of us do you choose
humorous one of us once and for all cherry bro thanks me
though of course i'm so glad you feel the same Oh my gosh,
she's even wearing a love-humorous t-shirt.
She's been turned down a second time.
The drama.
Why does my heart hurt so much?
They're both going to be sad.
Oh, wonder what's brewing with mocha.
Mocha.
So cute.
I want to try living with Angie.
What?
That's a great idea.
Wait.
What's something you think?
Oh my gosh, Meets can live together?
Ultra friends.
Oh, right.
Angie and Mocha go way back.
So why not reminisce?
The voice is so baby.
Let's have them talk about when the two of you first met.
Type about blinking.
You're right.
I'll go talk to her.
Can I have a word?
up mocha well if the two of us live together what's
something you think we'd enjoy doing every day
let's say it together on three one two blinking blinking
talking about when we met oh my god they're so insane let's
move in together oh roomies Look at your home.
Whoa.
Looks like they're really living the dream.
Living the dream.
Oh, Tomodachi Life Living the dream.
Angie looks much happier too.
Aww.
Here in this big old house, up to eight residents can live
together.
Oh my gosh, apartment complex.
You'll be able to see different sides of the me's when
they're under the same roof.
On three, say the first name that comes to mind Wait, that's
so much more like interactive interactivity between
everybody.
One, two, three, me.
And that's that.
We're at the concert!
The me on this island will live out their lives however they
so choose.
No more concert hall?
When is the game coming out?
Oh?
They might befriend someone.
When is the game coming?
Live together.
Always handling the clean up.
Or even fall in love.
Oh, the marriage.
See how their relationships change.
Baby.
Help them out where you can.
Oh, my God.
Rag doll.
There's other stores that they didn't highlight, it seems.
Like, my treasure.
I don't know.
That concludes a basic overview of Tomodachi life.
Living the dream.
Marriage.
What did you think?
Soon, it'll be your turn to create your own island.
Soon?
How soon?
What kinds of me characters will you make?
Tell us the date.
Tomodachi Life.
Living the dream launches on the Nintendo Switch system
April 16th.
April 16th!
The game will also be compatible with the Nintendo Switch 2
system.
Oh my gosh, I was worried I would have to get a Nintendo
Switch 2.
Why did I say the full name, full legal name?
Yippee!
Oh my gosh.
There's so much to it.
There's so much.
Wait, how long was that?
That was like 20 minutes long.
That could have been a normal direct, everybody.
This all could have been in a normal direct.
Actually, I guess it would have taken up half the direct
time, but...
Hold on.
I want to go see... Wait, let's see.
I want to go see a big map first, because...
Wait, like here.
No.
I'm seeing houses.
I'm seeing the news.
I wonder if we don't get the concert.
Maybe they'll add it in later.
you yeah but i'm pretty bummed about the concert hall
post launch updates i hope so i really hope so because that
was such a big part of the first game i'm trying to think of
features from the first game that they didn't show Tomodachi
lifeboads, ah, thank you.
Horse, wharf, jump, thank you.
Yeah, there was like the voting thing where you like said
like, raise your hand if you love pizza.
And like they would raise their hand.
There was that.
But we did see like the bowling thing.
I guess it's more like random events that happened
throughout the island rather than like a full section.
There was like the rat battles at the fountain in the
evening.
um so i'm probably probably that there's like random events
that happen throughout the island that they just didn't
feature um like the bowling that they showed randomly and
the dreams remember the the tomo the me's used to have
dreams and they would be like super wacky and you would get
items from them um with all the customization options vids
island is gonna be nothing but battle gear characters
featuring dante from the devil may cry series Corsat, thank
you so much for the 50 gifts and thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
They did say this is a basic overview.
True, true.
The island customization is like crazy.
Wait, what'd they show?
Uh, where they're like, you can make your island look like
this or like this or like this.
Like these, these new segments are the exact same as before.
It's so good.
Yeah, the build.
So...
Like so cute!
So cute!
And there's still the restaurant they didn't even show.
There's the nuts size area.
Tomoria.
That stayed the same.
I'm so happy.
But they didn't show that off at all either.
So...
We can have Densetsu and Tomodachi live.
Yeah!
We will!
i love this i love the pet that you can draw i'm gonna draw
ibu and take you guys on walks and the customization looks
really great for faces and stuff so so far it has very much
the spirit of the original so that's all i can ask for
Walkies!
Picking music in preference so good.
Yeah!
So much customization!
Thank you, stream schedule for the entire back half of
April.
Luckily, the entire end of April, I'm free.
Yeah!
Woo!
Yay!
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
Metal Gear Drama on the island.
I'm going to be shoving Ocelot and snaking each other's
faces.
Anyways, guys.
Well, that was fun.
That was a lot of fun.
Pomodachi Life Living the Dream.
Coming out April 16th, was it?
16th?
Living the dream launches on the Nintendo Switch system
April 16th!
Spoon for the Mindo helps the 70 hour work week go down!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the awkward soup!
But 70 hour work week!
Try and take it easy when you can.
Thank you for the watch along Mindo!
Thank you!
No, you don't need a Switch 2.
You can play on Switch 1 also.
I hope they all have the same features the Switch 2 game and
the regular Switch game I hope I hope
I don't want to have to get a Switch 2 yet I haven't had a
reason to yet so
graphics might be worse on one um do you see how they look i
think uh i think we're okay i think we don't need optimal
graphics for uh for tomodachi live live in the dream that's
just my opinion
in fact it looks the exact same of how it did on the ds so
how big of a crash out would you have if you make a metal
gear island and random Naomi shows up, then very awes a lot.
Everybody would be bisexual, so it would just enhance the
drama.
Anybody could get with anybody.
Oh my goodness.
The options are, it's a whole buffet, baby.
The drama is overflowing.
How many me's can we add on the island?
I don't think it's sad.
I think what the 3DS game was like 100 though or something.
So, I mean, that's a lot of me's.
100 me's is a lot of me's.
It looks like you can make a really large island.
Yeah, I'm trying to find.
I was trying to find the, uh, the, how they customize.
the island but so much happened in such a short amount of
time I couldn't I couldn't find it I love that they're just
like yeah you could make a clown and you can make a bear you
can get lion oh it was like here right yeah here it was here
yeah like these these are possible that's what I just said
these
I'm so in tuned.
Oh, yeah, let's look at here.
I see a bunch of, like, houses.
I don't get to watch you live much since I'm from Europe,
but I do enjoy your content, so I want to give some
appreciation while I can.
Oh, my gosh, a cutie.
Thank you.
Thanks for watching the boss when you can.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
One thing I was also hoping for, this is just me being
selfish, is, you know how there was the Ferris wheel.
There's also, like, there's, like, other areas, like an
observatory and stuff.
I think, though, with the extra customization, you kind of
build your own areas, if that makes sense.
So before you had, like, the observation area, I think
there's probably going to be ways to build that into the
game.
See, there's, like, a lighthouse there.
there might even be like events at the lighthouse like we're
not we don't we have no idea yet so um and it did show like
you picked up we picked up the guy and put him by like the
sprinkler and something happened you know so i think that um
i think that there's more obviously there's more that they
didn't show us i'm just like the concert hall i feel like
they would have shown that off was maybe that i don't know
no i want my knees to sing a musical so good would you
populate the island with your favorite version of each
character or introduce multiple snakes ocelots for maximum
drama i mean i guess we could do like an old ocelot and then
a young ocelot and then snake has to choose between the two
that would be drama the jp director has different characters
and stuff.
Oh, okay, well, I'll watch that later.
I'm gonna go take a nap now.
Actually, I'm gonna set up my waiting room for my stream
later, and then I'm gonna go take a nap.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me for the Tomodachi
Life Direct.
It was fun!
And I'll see you guys hopefully later for my next stream.
If not, then I'll catch you when I catch you next.
Otamito, everybody!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Nap time, nap time, nap time.
Put my glasses back on.
I'm going to snooze for a bit.
I can even snooze until it's actually my usual time that I
wake up.
Couldn't happen, Minto.
Back to not holding up international business.
Oh, that sounds important.
Bye-bye.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, thank you.
Bye-bye.